plusieurs types de vaccins contre le
coronavirus existe déjà dans le monde la
russie a elle seule 1 à élaborer 5 mai
les vaccins c'est de la prévention
contre la maladie et si on est déjà
malade les scientifiques russes ont
développé un médicament qui serait
efficace contre le coronavirus le remède
vient de passer la deuxième phase
d'essais cliniques et pourrait devenir
le premier médicament au monde pour le
traitement du co lead c'est l'institut
d'immunologie de l' agence fédérale de
biologie et de médecine qui a développé
mire 19 les résultats des études
précliniques ont été publiées en avril
dernier dans la prestigieuse revue
internationale allergy ce qui a poussé
des sociétés pharmaceutiques du japon de
la corée du sud à s'intéresser aux
médicaments us
à l'aide de ce médicament nous bloquons
très efficacement la multiplication la
réplication de ce virus en particulier
les études que nous avons menées en
phase pré clinique in vitro ont démontré
que l'utilisation du médicament mire 19
/ près de 10000 la charge virale est
bloqué la réplication du virus
nous travaillons maintenant sur la mise
à l'échelle sur la création d'une
technologie industrielle et bien sûr
j'espère vraiment que nous mettrons tout
en oeuvre pour diffuser le médicament
est que le prix n'affectera en rien sa
disponibilité pour la population à des
piqûres pas de comprimer le médicament
mire 19 est administrée se forment
d'inhalation comme le virus son filtre
dans l'organisme surtout par des voies
respiratoires supérieures
l'inhalation est le moyen le plus
efficace et le plus rapide pour faire
parvenir le médicament dans la zone
touchée par la maladie
prochaine étape pour les développeurs de
mire 19 l'enregistrement du médicament
auprès du ministère russe de la santé et
comme les chercheurs russes prévoient
d'exporter la technologie il s'apprête
également à publier les résultats de la
deuxième phase d'essai clinique dans une
revue scientifique internationale
mais la preuve ultime de l'efficacité du
médicament arrive au moment où la russie
munis de mire 19 fera face à une énième
vague de coronavirus